Anh sẽ như bạn nhắn thì rất thay và họ thay một điều rằng
ra, ở chỗ bị và nó mở tôi rất cạnh bệ trình bị.
Nhưng cái gì?
Cái gì?
Nó chuyện cho các bạn về tốt bà.
Tốt bà.
Điều các bạn cạnh về trình bị.
Chứ thí với và nó ở mở,
và giành cho tất cả ở sinh hai cà ta.
Hãy gà mở người luôn nhá.
Điều điện đó là chúng ta phải chọn được khu thi cho sinh mà thân mình.
Khu thi là khu thậm mà để chỗ táo thi theo rồi.
Và đồng thành mà nó xuất cả bà nó không?
Không chắc tâm.
Điều có thể ngon thi đe học mà thì rất là thấy một điều là rất ít mặt trọn được đối thú thi cho bạn thân mình.
Bây giờ nó rất nhiều bạn mong luôn.
Điều đi có bạn cạnh,
biết kinh nghiệp trọn khu thi phua,
bế bản thân,
có thể có mẹ thu gửi đây.
Điều có thể hỗ trợ và xuống trợ bạn cạnh trọn khu thi hiệu quả nhá.
Khai xuống hai đó là về tinh thái hại.
Hẹa chúng ta đã chơi một khoảng giang rất là dài.
Cảm ơn các bạn thế gián mà chúng ta rất là í chẹt,
cho các bạn chỉ chúng ta học tập.
Nó không?
Bây khi mình đã chở lại các bạn thấy là nó sẽ khó khăn hơn.
Nó chức khi chúng ta đang nghĩ học,
nó có quen với nhiều học.
Bây giờ các bạn cạnh với chở lại nó mùi tinh thằng học.
Hạnh mẹ hơn và các bạn có thể hiểu rằng,
tất cả những kinh thức người rồi chúng ta không thì đều sẽ thụ khu trọt.
Chúc khi thì thảo.
Bây giờ thì thì nó thì thì thích lúc mời nó mấy mỗi mỗi mấy ai.
Thúc mất giả như là ngày xưa chúng ta học.
Chỉ học lúc mấy ai ở đi tì thảo đâu.
Bị phần chơi là tính thằng học là một cái điều mà các bạn cạnh với cho mình.
Chúng ta bị tục lúc rồi.
Thôi tất cả những bạn khác.